do you think if you had a billion
dollars tomorrow you could maintain
being a normal person
like mentally or do you think you'd go
nuts
um get a billion dollars you know what
they say right I believe biggie
that do you want you're familiar with
this or do you want me to no jog my
memory it's something that's coming
um Mo Money Mo Problems that's what it
is I think if I had a billion dollars
yeah what about you I just buy a race
track and then just be a absolute weirdo
but even an absolute weirdo just buy
like a hundred cars I just drive them
naked and allow people to watch me drive
for free and but you have to be naked
yeah yeah no no yeah I'm the only one
that's naked yeah yeah I won't be naked
I'll wear a Speedo